uh hi i'm
chanwe lill i'm an associate professor
at european school of management
technology in berlin and i was educated
in university of cambridge and
since my phd time 10 years ago my
research topic is
always centering around the role of luck
and its
implication for business and society
i probably say everyone may have their
own definition
of luck and to me it's really just that
something unexpected
or random happened to us
but it also bring a very significant
consequence
good or bad if it's good and then we
call it uh we're lucky
and if it's bad and then we're unlucky
the definition of success is the
context-dependent
individual dependent right i teach in
esmt a business school so many people
will define success
like business performances and the
relation
of between success and luck is really a
complicated one
and actually that's the focus of my
research to what extent we can
attribute a success to their
skill interest equality or their effort
or
to being at the right place at the right
time that is luck
for example for business practitioners
my my research question has implication
for them because then
they have to decide to what extent they
should
reward their high performing employees
or to what extent they should imitate
their rivals
best practices
one of the great challenges i think my
research program can contribute
is really try to provide some remedy to
the social inequality we witness
in many different modern societies so
the question is really the social
inequality like the richest people
whether they deserve all the wealth they
obtained
if it's really like based on their
investment insight for example and their
effort of cold land that they serve
but my research findings suggest that
well if you're talking about the richest
a lot of factors beyond their control
matters a lot
and then implies that we should probably
adjust the tax
policy and also redistributed policy
but this is going to be very very
challenging of course so it needs more
and more rigorous evidence to support
these policy changes
so i would say this will be my next
grand challenge based on my research
program
i would like to think some of my
research finding and possible insight
can help
change the world and i think the two
main thing i focus on is the implication
of luck for business and also societies
so on business i really try to design a
policy or design way to help
organizations to promote and reward the
right person
rather than reward some people for their
good luck or bad luck
on the other hand the implication of
love for society is also really
important
because social inequality is huge in
many societies
and many of the the wealthiest people or
the most powerful people
they may not deserve all this attention
they
they got and my research finding can
suggest when
and to what extent this redistributed
policy should be designed
to attenuate the negative consequences
introduced by social inequality